where is Bix when we reunite with her is
she rebuilding from kind of being broken
by everything she went through and is
she going to be able to be part of the
rebellion in a way that some of the
other characters are oh my God you know
I cannot answer that I really want to
because it's a lot more interesting of
an answer than what I'm going to give
you
um
I think when we leave Bix we left her at
such a dark
um place she can barely walk she can
barely talk she's mentally incapable of
creating her own thoughts
um so from the first time we meet her to
when we leave her she's almost like a
completely different character and I
think what fans can expect is a lot of
reconstruction and a lot of Revelations
of how this trauma will affect her and
how does it affect her and
how does how does Biggs kind of cope
with this
um and who does she become because of it
we can talk about something that was
shown in the trailer oh yeah today
you want the tea yes I want all the tea
you want the tea I know is that the
reunion or is that later on what is what
is that scene that we saw what can you
say about it what I can say is that I
think
everyone should learn from season one
just how complex and Brilliant Tony
Gilroy's writing is and in season two it
happens again I think Simplicity and to
the point is something kind of Tony is
allergic to a little bit
um so everything will be
complicated even that beautiful shot